[Music]
thank you
as you saw from the sample photos and
videos there this is an impressive
camera system especially with the r
lenses this resolves higher much higher
than 24 megapixels in my personal
opinion it feels more like 30 plus
megapixels and I've said that in my
first impressions video so with that
said I'm not going to repeat all the
specs of this camera but I will talk
about what it's like to use so let's get
down to talking about that right now
this camera is very very easy to use and
it is a very welcomed upgrade over the
original R6 which is a 20 megapixel
camera which basically took the sensor
from The 1dx Mark III and put into that
camera system out there and it was the
baby brother to the R5 but in some ways
this has Trump the R5 especially when it
comes to Auto focusing but there are
some things that they've held back and
reason being this is a much more
budget-friendly more hobbyist prosumer
camera in the marketplace you're not
going to get all the the video specs
that a lot of people out there want
you're only going to be able to shoot in
C log 3 which is fine for the most part
most people with this camera system
aren't even going to shoot in log
they're just going to shoot with the
basic Canon profiles which are beautiful
by the way we're doing that right now
for this video and it looks great you're
gonna get 4k 60 and there's really no
overheating issues with this camera
system I think for the the design the
way they built it the way they've
improved it over the original R5 and R6
for that matter you're not going to face
those things and plus Canon is listening
they're realizing that they have to
create cameras that are going to
somewhat compete with their Cinema line
and they're gonna have to face the fact
that some people want to have a smaller
camera versus a big c200 or even C70 and
that's just the world we live in also in
terms of the other specs on this 40
frames per second an electronic shutter
mode which is phenomenal the fastest out
of any camera they have to date yes it's
going to some warping but it's not a big
deal and I think what Canon is doing is
saying look we're giving you a lot for
your money with the R6 Mark II we're
giving you more than Sony's giving with
the a74 but the lenses are more
expensive arguably from Canon especially
because they don't allow third-party
options into the marketplace right now
which is a big caveat when you're
getting into this camera but that's
something we'll talk about later on in
this video but outside of that you're
getting a much better autofocusing
system than arguably any other Canon EOS
R camera on the market yes even better
than the R3 in my personal opinion you
got AI built into this thing so you have
subject tracking that is much more
improved over any other Canon system and
you know that this is going to be going
into future Canon cameras can it come in
a firmware update who knows or will it
be let's say in the R5 Mark II if that
is a camera that will come out or maybe
the all-fabled Canon R1 will that ever
see the light or is that just a bunch of
tech Geeks out there wishing for that
camera to be we'll find out probably in
the future near future I'm I'm guessing
sometimes a lot of these camera
manufacturers they like to test certain
functionality in less expensive cameras
see how the general audience adopts to
them and then they will Implement them
into their flagships versus putting it
into a flagship and if it fails that
means the pros out there won't buy those
cameras and that means that's a big
problem another attribute that I really
like here is the ease of switching from
photo to video mode it took out in a few
years didn't it it took him a few years
but they figured out you just need to
switch and hopefully that switch stays
on every future camera that comes out
from Canon I don't want to dig into a
menu going to info this and press this
it's just it's convoluted you don't need
it switch is all you need one other
thing I like is the Simplicity of the
menu system especially for your quick
menu settings if you want to switch your
ISO really quickly you can actually tap
200 400 600 that makes life easier now
Canon has one of the easiest menu
systems in the marketplace Bar None this
video is brought to you by Asus check
out the Asus Zenbook 40 in X OLED Space
Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space with its space gray
durability it even comes with a 3.5 inch
OLED companion Zen Vision display and
you will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated display what are
some of the cons well if you want to use
HDMI to record you know 6K video don't
really think you need to in this camera
system but if you want to do that you've
got that micro HDMI port yeah or mini
HDMI whatever it is it doesn't belong in
a camera system anymore it's go for a
full-size HDMI port these things break
they're finicky and there's just no
reason for it another thing we have uhs2
car slots two of them now I granted I
get that this is a camera system that's
not meant for the pro photographers out
there are someone that might use CF
Express but I'll tell you what the R5
was brilliant in this way that you had
one slot for CF Express and one slot for
uhs2 now some people say well I want
redundancy I want to have two cards the
same okay valid argument but that CF
Express type B card is almost like a
mini hard drive in your camera system
and it's fast there's no buffering
issues but still it would be nice to
have one CF Express type B card slot and
one uhs2 you may disagree with me and
that's fine the evf is fine 3.69 million
dots it's bright it's vibrant High
refresh rate no issues with that but it
would have been nice to go at least five
you know what I mean it's a Mark II
camera system beef it up a little bit
overall I think this camera outside of
those few nuances is a fantastic camera
system would I recommend it yes but the
lack of third-party support that Canon
has implemented out there in the
industry for the RF Mount which I feel
is absolutely ridiculous and other
people have said the same thing as well
because these cameras while not that
expensive you want to get into some good
RF glass you're going to pay much more
than this camera alone that happens in
certain camera bodies and certain camera
manufacturers out there like up but it
doesn't need to be Sigma can make some
fantastic glass for this Tamron can make
some fantastic glass for this viltrox
could make some great glass for this and
they would come at a much more cost
effective and much more budget-friendly
option out there for people that want to
get into this camera yes you can buy EF
glass and adapt it and that's what a lot
of people are doing but if they can
bring us some more budget-friendly even
1.8 or F2 lenses out there into the
marketplace that are going to be much
more cost effective I think we're going
to see this camera flat the shelves and
rightfully so it's a fantastic camera
but don't try to make this a pro camera
it's not but if you're a hobbyist you
have a small business you say I want a
good camera for video for photography
great for all use purposes then this is
a camera I highly highly recommend
anyway those are my thoughts on the
Canon R6 quite a short review but
there's been plenty of videos out there
we did a first impressions already and I
gotta tell you I'm just waiting for some
less expensive glass but this camera is
freaking fantastic but if you like this
video check out more of our reviews
right here
[Music]